right so this is about non malleable
codes i hope i also have well I'll
motivate them and I'll also have some
stuff that hopefully you'll enjoy even
if you don't care about non valuable
codes but let me first try to make you
this is joint work of my student Ishaan
chattopadhyay so the one way to motivate
this is by trying to circumvent
classical bounds in coding theory as I
discussed in my lightning talk so if we
want to circumvent bands of course we
have to relax the requirements so the
first idea is to use a randomized
encoder and we'll have a deterministic
decoder this is deterministic as a
function it could be a randomized
algorithm but it will be deterministic
as a function and will only require to
correct coding with high probability
over the encoders coins in order to
explain that will need will need an
alternative view of corruption so as I
mentioned in the lightning talk our view
is the following so an adversary we
imagine an adversary deciding in advance
if code word C is sent I'll corrupt it
to F of C and doing it for each for each
code word so this defines a tampering
function from n bits to n bits and will
only allow the adversary to choose F
from some tampering function family so
this tampering function family is a
subset of all functions from n bits to n
bits so the most one of the most natural
ones is just an additive tampering
function family so for each error vector
E will just define the function f of x
equals x plus e so this is a natural
family and with randomized encoding Gore
Swami Smith's show that you can you can
achieve capacity in the worst case
setting so so here we allow any error
vector with weight less than PN
so this is this is better than pathans
is possible with deterministic encoding
in this sort of worst-case model where
we allow randomized encoding we're not
going to focus on error correction we're
going to focus on error detection so so
focusing on error detection several
authors defined algebraic manipulation
detection codes and here surprising that
you don't need any restriction on the
weight of e so again we have a
randomized encoder a deterministic
decoder that can also output error so
just detecting the error so what we want
is we want to be able to decode we want
the decoder to invert the encoder of
course for all for all strings s the
other condition is that a for any
message that's sent and for any error
vector e the decoder should it should
either output the original message or
output the string error at least it
should do this with high probability
with probability at least 1 minus
epsilon so it's a natural model that
they show that you can achieve rate
approaching 1 and there's some
cryptographic applications of this so a
lot of this is motivated by cryptography
so it's natural to ask can we tolerate
more tampering functions so we again we
want the decoder to invert the encoder
we and we want the decoder to output
either the original message or the or
error with high probability yeah we
can't even hunk handle constant
functions so if we have a function f
that always outputs the string W well
maybe w is the encoding of some string s
Prime so if we want to obey the first
property we better have the decoder
output s Prime but then then it will
violate the second condition if some
other message s is sent so we we can't
hope to achieve this
the saving grace here is that at least
the decoder output is uncorrelated with
the original string s so in our example
we're always outputting s Prime that's
not correlated with the message s and
sometimes these are the most dangerous
correlations so there's a whole field of
cryptography called non malleable
cryptography and here the the idea is
that you can't compute the encryption of
some function of a message given the
encryption of some message so in
contrast to our essay for example or
textbook RSA right if you square the
message so even if you if you're given
the encryption of some message you don't
know what the message is but from that
encryption you could compute the
encryption of the square of the message
and that's that's malleable and that
that can be dangerous in certain
situations so you want to avoid that and
that's sort of the motivation for for
this that we want to avoid this kind of
thing so that's so so it's in bouse key
features a canned wakes to find non
malleable codes in this manner so they
so again we have some fixed family of
tampering functions we have a non
malleable code with respect to f it
consists of a randomized encoder
deterministic decoder they invert each
other and and here's the main point that
for any tampering function either the
decoder is equal to s or it's
uncorrelated with us ok so at least we
don't have these these devastating
diverse area can't do something
devastating where they can they can
trick you into thinking a different
message was sent how do we formalize
that so we formalized it this way I
won't be using going into ok so here's
the formalization so we say that for any
tampering function there's some
distribution so this is going to be on
court there's a distribution that son
Carla doesn't depend on the message s so
this message this distribution is on all
all possible messages and the string
called same such that the following
holds
so let's let's put try to parse this we
have this function copy so if copy if if
the string DF takes the value same then
copy of saying why is why so so this
copy of DFS is just equal to s so this
just says we decode correctly and if the
copy if we don't if we never output the
value same then copy is just the first
string so then it's venice just saying
the decoder outputs this distribution DF
so either it outputs the distribution DF
that's independent of the message s or
it outputs s or really it really it's a
convex combination of those two
scenarios so this the encoder package
random so that that first line really
means that for every possible the
support of s in the distribution will
all be that back to a straight exactly
right right so good right there are many
different possible values of the of the
encoding of s and all of them have to be
decoded back to s yes
be something that common randomization
an encoder decoder tiger oh there's no
shared randomness the decoder doesn't
have access to the randomness that the
encoder uses yeah things become easier
if there's shared randomness but there's
nothing here
oh yeah sorry this is statistical
distance so the variation distance or
half the l1 norm
of course we're interested in the rate
and we're interested in this epsilon
that the error probability so let's just
look at an easy example that's when we
have these fixed functions these
constant functions that just output some
string W right so here for NES our
decoder will just output the decoder of
W and then we can we can choose any code
any code is non malleable with respect
to this because we can set DF to be the
decoder of W always and it will satisfy
the other definition is this that's sort
of trivia in general we may have any
subset of all the Dudley exponentially
many functions from n bits to n bits and
it's not hard to see their can't exist a
non valuable code against all functions
though the functions will be interested
in are called see split state well it's
the sea split state model so here we
have n bit we have all n bits we divided
into see blocks of length and oversee
and we allow an arbitrary corruption in
each block because we still have EE
exponential we still have a lot of
functions I mean it's doubly exponential
but not set all the functions
we want to handle these functions and so
the motivation for this is again
cryptographic so so there's it's useful
in Tampa resilience here if an adversary
tampers separate parts of memory
independently you can handle that with
something called tamper resilience
signature cards there's also there's
something called non malleable secret
sharing here the secret the shares of
all parties can be independently
modified usually that's devastating to a
secret sharing scheme but in this case
still the the coalition can't be fooled
into reconstructing a correlated secret
because I won't go into those but it has
some applications
okay so now what's possible so
existentially chirashi and guru Swami
showed that there are codes non
malleable codes in this model that
achieve rate approaching 1 minus 1 over
C with exponentially small error of
course we want explicit codes so the
first explicit code was Simba's key
casana and brents Abramski who should
who showed they showed how to Justin
code one bit messages so that was the
first the first to achieve polynomial
rate was agrawal dota sin lo vet Oh
chief polynomial rate pretty good error
jirachi and guru Swami looked at a look
at the bitwise tampering model so C
equals n you're allowed to tamper each
bit independently and they showed how to
get a trade approaching one with some
exponential error so r so our main
result we showed we showed how to get if
we just have c equals 10 we can achieve
constant rate and exponentially small
error and we can also get we can also
improve the mound of Mahdi and venkat by
getting exponentially small error
instead of this enter the 17 so again
prior to our work the best known was
this polynomial rate if you wanted any C
which is little o of n
okay so that's so that's the main result
here this constant sorry this one the
the constant rate not malleable code
okay so in the remaining time I want to
first I want to talk a little bit about
codes and randomness extractors so so
I'll talk this won't have anything to do
with non malleable codes so even if you
don't care about them you may care about
this and then i'll see i'll sketch the
construction i'll give a one side
introducing additive combinatorics which
is has interesting problems if you
haven't seen that so codes from
extractors we're going to use so we're
going to use it a connection discovered
by Mahdi and vet cat that certain not
malleable extractors given on malleable
codes but before defining that i'm going
to review randomness extraction so
randomness extractors are designed to
handle imperfect random sources and
there are many non obvious applications
in a variety of different areas so we
measure the randomness of a source by
its min entropy this tends to be more
convenient than entropy it's just the
you just look at the largest probability
of the distribution if the largest
probability is 2 to the minus K the men
entropy is K and so what you'd like to
do ideally is convert this low quality
randomness into high-quality randomness
you can't do this deterministically and
if all you have is a bound on the min
entropy but what you can do is you can
add a uniformly random seed why and then
the output of the extractor will be
close to the uniform distribution again
in statistical distance and this is
called a seated extractor and the length
of the sea doesn't even have to be very
big it could be just logarithmic and you
can achieve this a strong seeded
extractor does the same thing except it
has a somewhat stronger property that
the output of the extractor is uniform
even conditioned on the
seed why so this is interesting even if
the string Y is quite big the output of
the extractors is is close to uniform
even conditioned on the seed and we have
some very good seated extractors where
the min entropy as long as this at least
poly logarithmic we can output almost
all the randomness the output the output
length is say 99 percent of the manisha
p and the seed bank is logarithmic is
now let's talk about a connection with
coding so extractors relate to list
decoding in fact that there's I'll give
you an alternative proof of the Johnson
bound and lista coding viewing it as an
extractor so at a high level I'm just
going to say a code with good distance
is an extractor and an extractor gives
good lista coding so let's so let's look
at that so we're going to fix some code
with very high minimum distance so that
it's a binary code the distance is
epsilon squared away from a half and I'm
going to what i can do is define as a
strong seeded extractor as follows it's
the input to the extractor is the the
codeword this is sort of the the week
random source the imperfect random
source the seed is going to be an index
I in 1 through n so the extractor given
a code word and the index just outputs
VI ok so this is a very simple function
and I claim that it's a that is a strong
seeded extractor and this is this is
basically the the leftover hash limit if
you've seen that
so let's take a look what do we have to
show we have to show let v be some set
of code words that's has size at least
one over epsilon squared we have to show
that this that of the little V is chosen
from this set randomly and I is chosen
uniformly at random the extractor output
will be close to uniform so that's so
that's what D is d is the distribution
of epic I uniformly at random and V from
our set of vectors V we want to show
that d is close to uniform I'll show
that it's a strong seeded extractor why
is this we can just analyze this by
looking at the collision probability of
this distribution the collision
probability means we sample twice
independently from this distribution and
we look at the probability that they're
equal and so it's basically an l2 norm
ok so we sample twice from this
distribution d what's the probability
that they're equal well the problem we
sample an eye and deny prime from 1
through n the probability that those are
equal is exactly 1 over N now let's
assume i equals i prime we sample v and
v prime independently from the set of
vectors v well a V equals V prime then
these are equal that happens with
probability 1 over the size of V if he
doesn't equal the prime then we know
that they're there in my there are most
n minus D coordinates where they're
equal because the distance is d so there
are at most n minus D coordinates where
they're equal so will the probability
that we get it that that VI equals V
prime I is is at most 1 minus D over N
and that's that's basically it if you
work it out you get this one plus 4
epsilon squared over 2 N and if and it's
not too hard to see just going from l2
l1 that this implies that the
statistical distance from DD uniform is
less than epsilon okay so it's you know
if I went to quickly it's easy to go
home and just double-check this
okay and now we're ready to prove the
Johnson ban it follows like almost one
line so here we have a code so what the
Johnson ban says that there aren't too
many code words with within distance
half minus epsilon of a received word
are okay so why is that so let v be the
clothes code words and let DB this
distribution that we just discussed but
I claim that that that D minus u is at
least epsilon because there's a
statistical tests showing this namely we
just look at the probability that I VI
equals I comma the received word I these
vectors are all in are all within half
minus epsilon of the received word that
means the problem that they equal RI is
at least half plus epsilon so this is so
this probability is at least half plus
Epsilon but in the uniform setting it
would be just exactly half so that
distinguishes if by epsilon by epsilon
okay and then by the previous what we
saw previously if he is at least L then
the these differ by less than epsilon so
that's a contradiction so this is a this
is a proof of the Johnson bound via
randomness extraction so it's kind of
neat that these two seemingly just
different areas independently have
basically the same
okay so that's an aside so ok back to
not malleable so I have like okay so
here's so so in order to define the
right kind of extractor I need to first
let me tell you a seat Adnan malleable
extractor is it's a it's a strengthening
of a strong extractor so in a strong
extractor we conditioned on the seed why
now we're not only conditioning on the
string why but we're conditioning on the
extractor output of a with it with a
correlated seed F of Y so f of f is any
function with no fixed points and we
still get to see the extractor output of
X with F of Y we still shouldn't be able
to predict the extractor output of x and
y so for example if the extractor
ignores a bit of the seed it's not not
malleable because then this function f
can just flip the bit that's ignored and
and then the extractor output of X f of
y will equal the extractor output of x
and y and and this won't hold so it's a
very strong definition it takes some
time to get used to Oh in some earlier
work we did succeed in constructing
these
so but the real extractor that then mati
and Venkat introduced is slightly more
general now you're allowed to corrupt
not just not just a sea but you're
allowed to corrupt all the inputs to the
extractor so now you're given C
independent sources you're allowed to
corrupt all x 14 x c and you still have
this property that even get conditioned
on that the aput is close to uniform so
it takes some time to digest but this is
this is what what's needed right so it
was introduced by traduction khursani
who should they showed the probabilistic
existence and the question was can you
construct it and so also Mahdi and
Venkat showed that if you can construct
such a see the Sun malleable extractor
then you have your non malleable code
and the non malleable code is is easy to
define the decoder is actually the non
malleable extractor the encoder inverts
the inverts the extractor so it picks a
random element from the inverse image of
of the message so the inverse image of
the extractor and so we have so this
gives a code so I'll just say that so
weak sick we manage to construct this
extractor and then by their result plus
we had to give an efficient sampler for
this non malleable extractor we gave a
non malleable code and then by another
reduction of my mcat we got the other
result for bitwise tampering
um so let me so I have what five minutes
let me go ahead and try to get something
okay so you could show that some other
things fail let me so just to get a
sense of why this is hard you know
here's something that fails right so
this is actually a seated on malleable
extractor but it fails in this setting
because the extractor could corrupt x 22
x could corrupt y to y over 2 and then
and then the extractor of f with these
corrupted inputs actually equals the
extractor on x and y so it's it's it's
it's hard to think of candidates here
okay so what we did what we did was come
up with an intermediate goal the
intermediate goal was just to say that
given this these the extractor output on
these corrupted strings w that we want
still has some entropy I won't go into
that but the me let me just introduce
additive combinatorics in case some of
you haven't seen it I'll just say a few
words about that so you're even if you
didn't follow what I was saying you
could tune in again so so this says so
here we define if any is a set of
integers an A plus a is the set of
pairwise sums and you can see that this
is useful you know it came up in the
talk on polar codes where they're
looking at some sets so you could ask
how big can the set be a plus a so a
plus a it can be less than 2 a of a is
an arithmetic progression similarly you
can have any times a less than 2 ay if
ay is a geometric progression and what
air der stone and allocations and some
improvement show that they can't both be
small at the same time so this is over
the reels for the moment they show that
either the either the sunset or the
products that has to increase the size
of a by a noticeable amount
and what's useful is that Brigance cats
and thao showed that this holds even in
finite fields so in finite fields of
course you can't take a to be the whole
finite field then it can't grow but as
long as a so we're working on FB if a is
if a is at most ptoo the point nine then
you get some bound like this with a
smaller constant but bigger than one and
this and this is useful this has had
applications and this is and we use
things related to this in fact so one
thing thats related is if a B and C have
equal size then the size of a B plus C
grows somehow you can't you know the
only way to prevent a B from growing is
if they're sort of designed to handle
multiplication and then they're not
designed to handle addition and then it
grows so these kinds of this property
has found a bunch of uses and this is
another example that we found so we
using it directly doesn't work but what
we do is our idea is sort of to encode
the sources so we encode sources by X
and then some polynomial it turns out
this polynomial is a good polynomial to
choose and then our then to achieve the
intermediate go we just need to do some
we just need to add in coatings and this
is coordinate wise multiplication so we
just need to add in coatings and do
coordinate multiple coordinate wise
multiplication do it a couple of times
we achieve the intermediate goal and
then our final thing is w is the
intermediate goal then we have to use
the seeded non malleable extractor which
has been done earlier with with the
remaining two sources of seed and that
gives us our non malleable extractor and
to do this we have to prove a we have to
do some some product estimate it's hard
to parse this but you just have to know
that things work out well as long as as
long as your said is not contained in
certain planes that look
of a certain form and our encoding
ensures that the these AI JS intersect
with the plains of that formants in few
places and that that's a very high level
vague idea of what's going on okay so in
conclusion we give the first constant
rate non valuable code in the sea split
state model for any seed little o of n
we achieve c equals 10 there's actually
a new reduction of agrawal dode does
cassano Abramski they so combined with
that you get c equals 2 so they show how
to how if you get any constant you can
get the constant down to two and will we
achieve optimal error and so we can and
we can also do well in the bitwise case
so open questions so our our rate is
constant but it's still a small constant
can we get rate close to half or at
least something you know that i could
tell you publicly are there other uses
of non malleable codes so can i make you
care about them more than you do now are
there better non malleable extractors
and finally are there further
connections between coding theory and
randomness extraction know that there
are several interesting ones and i think
there's more there thanks
so as your food together Johnson bar but
all I distance penalty for all you're
getting it subsided before what the
distances you know white one so you mean
yeah but I think you could just choose
epsilon in the binary setting you can
choose absolutely i think so need to be
smaller groups but it works for anything
i think so this constitutes they make so
we can't you don't have to lose
constants because you know right I I
yeah so I'm I've got a hundred percent
sure but I think it I think it does
match it
my questions so if not I guess we're
done for today